Ted Cruz talks pretty tough when it
comes to fighting Isis
we will carpet bomb them into oblivion I
don't know if sands can glow in the dark
but we're gonna find out while this type
of bold rhetoric may win votes
carpet bombing is actually a very
problematic military strategy the
unofficial phrase carpet bombing refers
to a strategy used by the Allies in
world war ii to saturate mostly civilian
areas of germany and japan with bombs
essentially laying a carpet of bombs the
bombing of German cities in particular
the end of the war caused incredible
numbers of civilian casualties and the
bombing of Hiroshima and Nagasaki may
have caused Japan's surrender but at the
cost of hundreds of thousands of mostly
civilian lives these were not surgical
strikes on the military but
indiscriminate bombing campaigns and so
at the end of the war world leaders
decided that carpet bombing or
indiscriminate attacks on large areas
without regard for civilians would be
strictly forbidden
so what Cruz is suggesting violates
international law the areas that Isis
controls are full of civilians there's
no critical mass of military activity or
infrastructure to target also the us-led
coalition has already put so many
missiles and bombs into the campaign
against Isis that the US Air Force
actually recently reported it was
beginning to deplete its stockpile as of
late Cruz has started to alter his
terminology perhaps realizing his
blunder
now when I say saturation carpet bombing
that's not indiscriminate but Cruz needs
to check his phrasing because by
definition the very nature of carpet
bombing is that it's indiscriminate
finally think about this in its videos
Isis has repeatedly used the bombing
campaign in Syria as an excuse for its
attacks claiming that they're just
retaliating indiscriminate bombing that
kills enormous numbers of civilians
could in turn make the civilians who've
lost everything more sympathetic to Isis
and that is not a way to win over the
hearts and minds of the American people
or
anyone else